living conditions were already
challenging in this camp for displaced
Yemenis now severe flooding has made it
worse more than 1,500 makeshift homes
have been destroyed in a Kadesh camp one
of many affected in haja province
displaced families are now trying to
rebuild their straw homes with whatever
they can find like many families here
fatima lost all she had when she was
displaced now everything has gone again
as a widow she says her family now
depends on this breadmaker
we need help organizations have come in
but they've just taken our photograph
and registered our names we don't have
anything the United Nations estimates
the floods have affected more than
80,000 people in recent months leaving
many in need of food shelter and
sanitation we've been suffering here for
more than seven months from rains
windstorm and diseases the houses here
are all destroyed some organizations
have tried to rebuild homes but they
leave them with no roofs or cover people
have died but many aid organizations are
spread thin fighting between Houthis and
allies of Yemen's internationally
recognized government pushed the country
to the brink of famine and that was
before the flooding I used to have
little bit of cooking flour but the
floods washed it all away we don't have
anything to eat everything was flooded
may God have mercy on us on our children
people living in these camps have little
support and nowhere to go they can only
hope that help come soon
Kotsay a little piece of a yawn
al-jazeera